While we could solve our problem by calling our draw function with
setInterval or setTimeout, the better way is to use requestAnimationFrame.
requestAnimationFrame, only sends a request if the last frame is
already finished drawing, or the window is actively being viewed.
setInterval and setTimeout, execute no matter what.
So if your drawing takes a really long time to finish a single frame, and
your interval is really small, it can cause your browser to slow down or crash.
So when I add a call to requestAnimationFrame, after this drawImage call here.
It makes sure the canvas gets updated.
So when we hit Play, it should keep it in sync.